Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Recently, Charlie Hunnam
just revealed that he was supposed to be Zack Snyder's
version of Green Arrow Inside the DCEU movies.
There were so many theories
about this several years ago.
This finally confirms a lot of them.
So we'll break it all down and explain what happened.
But now don't the Green Arrow jokes on Peacemaker
make a lot more sense
It kind of
sounds like they were making fun
of that version of Green Arrow would have been like,
instead of Stephen Emile's Green Arrow,
which at the time, because Stephen Amell
was the only version of Green Arrow
we had, people assumed that the joke
was about his version of Green Arrow.
but if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of really big stuff coming up in the DC
Universe and just related big stuff in general.
So I'll try to do videos for everything.
But you probably saw recently in your feed
Charlie Hunnam was promoting
Zack Snyder's Rebel Moon Netflix movie
that's being released right now.
it's kind of like Zack Snyder's version of a Star Wars
movie that started life
as an actual Star Wars movie
that he pitched to Lucasfilm before J.J.
Abrams was hired to do The Force
Awakens back in the day.
And before Zack Snyder was hired to do his DC movies
with Man of Steel,
during that movie,
Charlie Hunnam plays a Han Solo rogue type of character.
So I'll talk about that at the end of the video.
I'll be doing separate videos for that.
But during a recent interview for that,
he just flat out reveals that DC
and Warner Brothers had meetings with him
about becoming the new DCEU Green Arrow.
This is the clip of him talking about it.
His reaction at the time.
When Zack was doing DC movies, you were the fan
just to be his Green Arrow did,
and you still are kind of.
Well, did that ever almost happen
Do you ever talk to him about that
I never talk to him about it.
But you talk to someone.
I don't. I don't remember.
I don't honestly, I don't remember who.
Yeah, it was. It was. It was some people in suits
brought the
idea to me and thought it would be terribly exciting
for me to play Green Arrow.
And I did not share their enthusiasm.
Okay, fair enough, man. I think it'd be cool.
I don't know who Green Arrow is,
so I don't want to offend anyone.
No, no, I just.
I looked at one picture and I was like,
I'm not sure Green's my collar and I'm pretty sure.
And spandex is my material.
And beyond that, I was like, one image.
Thanks. I'm not interested.
so when he's talking about it there.
You have to keep in mind
this would have been happening years ago
like Warner Brothers and DC didn't just speak to him
recently about being Green Arrow in the movies
because literally James Gunn
just announced his big reboot with Superman Legacy.
There's slate of new movies
and TV shows and new versions of the characters,
like the recasting most of the really major characters.
so anybody that's been talking to DC right now
about being in the upcoming movies
would be for like James Gunn's DC new movies,
the way they Charlie Hunnam talks about it.
It sounds like the studio at the time
were trying to get a Green Arrow movie going in.
They were probably planning on using him in other Zack
Snyder, DC movies that would have gotten made
had he continued to make DCEU movies and just in
general had the DCEU continued in James Gunn
not been hired
But even weirder like even funnier thing in all this
is that he says when they called him about this,
he had never seen
or even heard of the Green Arrow character before
And even though there are some really obscure comic book
characters out there, like the Guardians of the Galaxy
were pretty obscure before James Gunn blew them up
big time with his first movie.
I would not call Green Arrow an obscure character.
It's sort of like meeting a middle age
or like an older person
who's never seen any of the original star Wars movies.
Like Where have you been this whole time? Like,
they've everywhere.
It's all over pop culture. How do you miss that?
did you grow up on another planet?
Were you not allowed to read anything
or see any magazines when you were a little kid?
after checking Charlie Hunnam his personal history.
I think the explanation there is that he is
grew up in northern England and during the eighties,
when he would have been a little kid,
you get exposed to this kind of stuff, typically
at that time in England,
there weren't a ton of American comics
outside of like the very major ones, like Spider-Man,
Batman, Superman, like the most popular comics
in especially in the more remote places,
like the more remote towns and just in general.
American comics weren't nearly as huge a thing
in England during that era of history.
So it's a little easier to understand
how he could have just completely missed out
on a lot of those characters growing up.
it's not like today
where superheroes are like, literally everywhere.
Zack Snyder revealed a lot of details about
what would have happened in his Justice League trilogy
had he gotten to make it.
I don't remember him specifically
talking about the Green Arrow character himself,
but My assumption is that Charlie Hunnam is Green Arrow
movie stuff would have happened after the first Justice
League movie had come out, and they would have just
cameoed him in the Justice League sequels somewhere.
They'd done a spin off
Green Arrow movie with Black Canary.
Other characters in the Green Arrow comics like Roy,
his family, most of the characters that you saw
during the Arrow TV show Inside the Arrowverse.
now, when you think about it, you also do remember
this would have been going on while Stephen Hamill's
Arrow show was still running The same way Zack
Snyder cast Ezra miller to be The Flash in the movies,
while Grant Gaston's Flash was still running
to make as many flash puns as possible,
they finally paid that whole meta off.
During the crisis on Infinite Earths crossover episodes.
the even crazier thing to me is that Grant Gustin
revealed on a panel that he was doing it
at Comic-Con convention is that he was never asked
by any official Warner Brothers
people to be in the Flash movie do a cameo scene,
which is just crazy to me.
Like, how do you not even ask him to do it?
it sounds like at the time Charlie
Hunnam was asked to be the movie version of Green Arrow,
he either didn't like superhero movies in general or
just didn't care, or they gave him a really bad pitch.
Or he just didn't like the whole concept
of the Green Arrow character himself.
he didn't say exactly which movies
he would have appeared in
or what they pitched to him or what year exactly
they started talking to him.
That would help a lot if we knew exactly what year
he was being talked to about this.
it sounds like instead of becoming Green Arrow,
he decided to do that
King Arthur movie in a couple of non
IP movies and TV series.
called him and I said, I know
you're not at all offering me this role,
but could I please have it?
And this is the reason why. And I just loved him.
but he does talk about loving working with Zack Snyder
so not being Green Arrow
didn't have anything to do with Zack Snyder
specifically doing the DC movies.
I think the idea, though, is that Charlie Hunnam
Green Arrow would have been a little bit
more of an injustice type of Green Arrow
since the whole vibe of Zack Snyder's DC movies
as a Justice League movies was more like the injustice
universe versions of the characters.
So if Stephen Amell is version of Green Arrow
was meant to be a more hardcore take on the character,
you have to imagine Charlie
Hunnam would have been an even darker,
even more hardcore, bloodier version of the character.
Stephen Amell has talked a lot
about how they created the Arrow series
to be a way more grounded
take on superheroes in the Smallville Green Arrow.
I love though, when they started meeting at conventions
like this is their version
of that crisis on Infinite Earths Flash crossover scene.
but Stephen Amell said that they did that with Arrow
because of the influence of Christopher
Nolan's Batman Dark Knight movies.
Batman Begins and The Dark Knight had both been released
when they started developing era.
Christopher Nolan, Christian Bale's
Batman had made so much money
in was so overwhelmingly popular
that all DC superheroes and movies after that tried
to recreate the magic of The Dark Knight
with all their other heroes.
that's why you probably heard talk
about how Warner Brothers tried to Dark Knight
Superman with Henry Cavill's
Man of Steel, like Make a Superman movie,
but with more hardcore
horror vibes that are way more grounded.
Feeling like The Dark Knight.
So if the Arrow episodes
felt like they were aping Batman
Begins and The Dark Knight,
and that's because they were specific.
Like Stephen Amell said that when he went for
some of his first meetings with the character
and the production had pictures of Batman Begins
and The Dark Knight plastered all over their offices
and even further back
Stephen Amell talked about being in the Justice
League movies like the DC movies
when he started doing Arrow Season one.
how successful The Avengers has been.
Now we have Chris Nolan, you know, sort of shepherding,
but yeah, it would be.
It would be it would be amazing to me
to be involved in stuff that expanded
beyond beyond television onto the big screen, but
maybe will expand beyond this series into other series.
keep in mind when he was doing that interview,
it was around 2010, 2011 before Arrow Season
one came out, and that was when Zack Snyder had
just started to make and release the Man of Steel movie.
And at the time he said the studio didn't speak to him
about their upcoming plans to do Justice League
like build their version of an MCU
with the Justice League movies.
so when he was hired for Man of Steel.
It was just for man of steel.
But then when he came back to beat
on a Man of Steel sequel, they pitched in the idea
for Batman v Superman, like Put Batman in Your Man
of Steel sequel and make it more of a Batman movie.
then they pitched in the idea for the Justice League
movies, and then they hired him for Batman v Superman.
They also hired him to do the Justice League movies,
which is why so much of Batman v
Superman is dedicated
to setting up the Justice League movies.
he specifically designed moments
in that they would pay off during the Justice
League sequels, for example,
that Batman in Flash time travel scene.
They were going to pay that off until Justice
League two.
I did a whole separate video about the full plot
of Justice League Two and Justice League three.
Zack Snyder was really nice to release his plans
for those into the wild a while ago.
they're every bit as crazy
as you would expect them to be.
So I'll post a link for that at the end of this.
but let me know.
In the comments they still wind up
doing a version of Green Arrow in the future.
DC movies.
What do you want them to do with the character?
Assuming it'll be a totally different
take from what they did with the Stephen Amell version
in the Arrowverse like this will be in James
Gunn's DCU movies.
maybe we'll even see him in like a future season
of Peacemaker to pay off his Green Arrow Brony jokes.
there's a bunch of really big stuff coming up.
My Rebel Moon video will post next week
after they release it on Netflix and my Marvel
What If Season 2 Episodes we'll start posting
next week after they start releasing them too
Everyone click here for that brand new Superman Legacy
announcement and click here to learn
about the full plot of Justice League
2 and the Justice League 3 movies.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!